o lado pessoal de quem fala é o temor ou
não eu sou daqui é bom hoje temos aqui
no 2 night at black edition
empreendimento jogador bisou e não sei
que consegui ensinar o ac milan flamengo
agora foi o que é isto
o eca
rosinha primeira noite de ontem mais
comandos e que não quer saber cala a
boca eu em todo jogo há sempre uma
vozinha fica lá em cima falar e ele não
quer saber para o tempo de queijo
cheinhos - tem o que esta gente mesmo
não funcionam não funciona mesmo há há
há ok nós em vista tocaram e agora nos
séculos nós podemos usar equipes e times
conrado à cinta muito mais fácil muito
mais fácil assim os quatro e marrone que
estão aqui agora é só torcer pelas
lentes de palhaço está lá atrás eu disse
para ele eu não sei se continua a abrir
ou não não ela continua fechada por está
tudo tranquilo tranquilo
oto funk
o suspiro por cima de qualquer coisa
senão não se luz não os recalls em um
deck um décadas e carro que alguém
estava lá na casa do campeão pelo seu
carro não já não sei eu já não sai opera
o cão se possível daqui possa me tucão
está aqui então quem é que está o linux
flair homem que quem está lá em cima
andré conicet aí eu tenho um naco nenê é
o novo tema tronic então agora cinco
animatronics não sabe se contará com o
seu pedaço
aí você pegar se adaptar à lei traz não
só deixaram entrar
não não tá tranquilo aqui ok
aparentemente a única coisa que tudo
isso fui destinarem mais um animal
throne e este time flui tão tipo a
navegação aqui dentro do segmento nem
sei o que é que isto está aqui uma casa
isso ou eu sei
a primeira noite muito fácil à la bocca
e vamos começar por james cameron
tudo aqui está tudo tranquilo o set
estava em cima eu acho é eu acho que
continuo dos e palhaços abriu nesta
noite exatamente temos que tomar atenção
agora que você pagar só a opa é rechã
subiu de quem já lá vão sua equipe à
frente ou não não ela não está aqui ou o
resultado ora quem fuma mil views fez
uma cara meio tem muito bizarro mas com
a cara dela ae 7 já está lá em cima é
chata lá em cima sim ok allright ainda
está lá em cima
aqui perto não está ninguém eu acho que
em cima também não está ninguém o que
quer dizer que eles não vão estar à
porta agora eu preciso ouvir horas são
quatro da manhã já meu deus toma só fala
muito bem resolvido isto muito funk que
não me gêmeos som através da série já
repararam que rights ou tá comendo um
lado anel que o microfone na boca
sou eu é confundir o microfone sou eu é
possível e já saiu daqui né então que os
4 é muito bem a fim de que alguém foi
rechaçada um novo microfone com ela ou
eu apoiei o que explicar o meu deus ela
viu que eu fui verificar a câmera e ela
por cima aqui pra lavar que então tá
tudo bem eu volto como eu culpo escala
disso mas não vou deixar lixo não vou
deixar bolha 80 porque abrirá mil não
enchesse é muito assustador assim eu
acho que vocês deveriam desempenhar
cinéma junto com uma curtinha já estava
quase toda aberta ck1 de actuar no
check-out e não encontrou zé camilo
cantar i'll de jantar na porta do hotel
na porta
vai querer sair feche a porta não fecha
a porta fecha não é essa festa será que
eu vou embora
não sei se o palhaço precisa já cortei a
faixa fosse todo meu deus do céu foi
embora não acho que já possibilita a
porta eu acho que sim
o oscar foi isso que foi josé caos que
foi do zé carioca é isso é porque o boi
tolo aqui a rechousa por seu por
completo já não encontra rechã o campo
também não sei nem cantar
ai ai jucá trabalha junta tem que ficar
atenta às portas e agora pretende ficar
muito atenta às portas e eu podemos
vista e anunciando que custou a eu estou
aqui os dois ok a região eo carro agora
que era preciso salvar tudo tranquilo
aqui o kaká e eu continuo quis 15 do
enem é pessoal é só voltarmos aqui mais
um pouco e nós conseguimos passar esta
noite vamos falar não saiu daqui por
favor ela vai perceber esta porta oikos
que olha o meu nome eo tamanho do lá e
conseguir conseguir conseguir sair
amanhã seria noite agora pessoal
preparado o vosso cup para o vosso
cozinho lindo porque vamos agora buscar
a terceira noite é uma noite que nós
nunca tínhamos gato né
ok vamos lá eu não quero saber não não
há nem tendo foco não apenas quatro tudo
que tá tudo bem tá
não acredito que ela está aqui pra baixo
não não não não
a única questão que eu podia ser vista
porque se você tiver um tal de crianças
destaca josé público ao interpretar a
lei naquela solas eu estou na porta já
curte né oxarada rotina continua havendo
aqui perto e ouvir meu sério eu juro que
eu vou apresentar o meu o meu golzinho
está bem apertado é eu tô havia 1 29 em
diluição e ouviram de qualquer coisa -
estou muito satisfeito e vou entrar
dentro da câmara só para ver o que está
acontecendo porque senão todos aqui
todos caraças
ai meu deus queira continuar para que
não esqueça continuou já estava toda
aberta toda vez que ela tava eu preciso
ver que ela chama sul três da manhã a
questão já contava em que o demitiu o
dmc world no chão
tudo isso vai ver câmera ok eu sinto do
inem estão nesta sala aqui tá tudo
escuro aqui não está ninguém nesta sala
o tal de porco 10 por fama por ser desta
porta aqui né
ah eu puxar importa sem olhar pra lhe
posso dizer isso
lol o llao llao o lance é muito mais
fácil - eu estava preocupado em fechar
as portas
assim é muito mais foco em fácil vocês
já ouviram um não
hoje estou aqui num tom 8,6 das passadas
por tudo o que ele já não há ninguém
precisa ver horas e horas com cinco
também é mais uma hora é mais de uma
hora dar 500 ou mais uma folga embora lá
no lote das 4 horas
o futebol não está na porta de uma
cortina duas caras sinto bem
não sei mas não vai acontecer nada aqui
também não dê tempo para achar que eu
estou fazendo isso não saiu qualquer
pessoa nos três dias que nós temos que
estar obrigatoriamente tendo já curte né
e estas duas portas nós não precisamos
ver a câmera para nada só precisam estar
atentos o barulho e estas portas ea
cortina é mais nada não precisamos mais
nada começar a controlar bem as portas
do mundo embora não né
não sei porque era ai meu deus eu quase
que nem consigo fazer um comentário em
contexto oscar isto é muito difícil eu
nem sei que horas são eu nem quer saber
eu não vou ver as horas eu só quero
ficar atenta às portas do juro eu vou
buscar a minha cueca hoje mesmo a sério
embora tá resultar pessoal a resultar e
eu só tô controlar souto controlar as
portas
e cortina que está tudo bem na capital
continua rápido caroços bota só precisa
ficar atento aos brut eu não preciso
virar câmeras que vai conseguir
conseguir a terceira noite pessoal eu
não consigo ficar mais distante ou não
depor hoje e vão pessoal curso que eles
passaram a terceira noite já não é nada
mal né
aparentemente já existe mesma quarta
quinta e sexta à noite o que quer dizer
que nós vamos ter uma série desta deste
jogo e espero fazer isso não está já
sabem quanto como a flec favorito e quem
foi a culpa micro fiquem bem até a
próxima